queer people make history all the time
even if your teacher forgot to mention
that part
hello and welcome to an episode of
historical icons who weren't actually
straight today's icon is james baldwin
he was a civil rights era american
author writer and playwright who
illustrated the struggle of his fellow
black americans with a unique and
nuanced voice he championed love and
emotional connection as a powerful and
necessary force for change on top of all
of that he was queer
up first some fast facts
baldwin was born on august 2nd 1924 and
grew up in poverty in harlem new york
with his family his mom abusive
stepfather and eight half-siblings eight
i only have one and that's more than
enough his extraordinary gift for words
first shown as a 14 year old junior
minister and with stories and plays he
wrote for his high school dwight clinton
he later chronicled this period of
self-exploration through religion and
sexuality with his first novel go tell
it on the mountain by his mid-20s
baldwin fed up with america's
mistreatment of black people and wanting
to see himself outside of that context
secured a writing fellowship that
allowed him to move to
paris
baldwin bloomed creatively publishing
many of his most celebrated works like
giovanni's room and notes of a native
son a powerful essay collection on
racial inequality over time his french
riviera home became a kind of refuge for
other black revolutionary artists oh to
be a fly on that wall baldwin was also
close friends with many other
influential people of the time like
marlon brando maya angelou and ray
charles
in 1957 the civil rights movement was in
full force and baldwin returned to
america an incredible 1965 debate that
you should definitely go watch between
baldwin and william buckley shows
baldwin's virtuoso ability to paint in
clear words the painful realities of
being black in america saying it comes
as a great shock to discover that the
flag to which you have pledged
allegiance along with everybody else has
not pledged allegiance to you
following the assassinations of his
close friends and civil rights giants
medgar evers malcolm x and martin luther
king baldwin returned to france to
recover from his grief
he then wrote some of his most powerful
works shining a light on black love and
humanity by telling the stories of black
families his 1974 novel the
heartbreaking if beale street could talk
tells the story of a young black couple
whose dreams are torn apart by a false
rape accusation in a racist police
system baldwin's words contributed
immensely to the movement in their own
way as he put it we can disagree and
still love each other unless your
disagreement is rooted in my oppression
and denial of my humanity and right to
exist
now on to the quiz
baldwin dated men but he viewed his
sexual identity through a broad lens and
shouldn't we all he chose to view and
love people as themselves resisting
sexuality and gender-related labels
which he saw as pointlessly shifting
over time
one of baldwin's most significant
relationships was with a swiss painter
named lucian hackersberger they lived
together for a few months in a small
chalet in 1951 which honestly sounds
amazing
it was there that baldwin was able to
write uninterrupted and experience a
slice of domesticity with a partner for
the first time in his life although
their relationship ended and baldwin was
devastated they remained on good terms
never afraid to write about love in ways
that were socially unacceptable for the
times in 1951 baldwin wrote giovanni's
room dedicated to lucien deemed very
controversial it's centered around the
lives of gay white characters living in
paris
giovanni's room came to be a success and
helped make space for the representation
of gay life in literature he continued
to normalize queer relationships by
writing books that featured queer
characters like the best sellers another
country and just above my head during
the years that baldwin returned to
america to participate in the civil
rights movement he was prevented at
times from taking a more active role as
some religious leaders and black
activists because of his sexuality and
relative to them more tempered views
undeterred he continued to write and to
speak where he could unapologetically
expressing his own beliefs
baldwin died in 1987 of stomach cancer
with lucian at his bedside more than 30
years after their affair
in conclusion
james baldwin was a huge intellectual
influence on the civil rights movement
wrote enduring works of literature
normalized queer characters in his
writing and had a cute artsy boyfriend
throughout his life voldemort was
unflinching in his belief that people
who identified as lgbtq were worthy of
love and respect despite the outright
hostility he often encountered he is now
regarded as a hero to several trans
activists like janet mock because of his
advocacy for androgyny and non-binary
identities in his later writings
especially in his essays here be dragons
and to crush the serpent his writing and
message resonate with the ongoing battle
for equality today
if you haven't seen raul peck's
documentary i am not your negro based on
baldwin's unfinished final memoir or
barry jenkins academy award-winning
adaptation of if bill street could talk
put them on your weekend list
[Music]
thanks for watching and check out the
next episode of historic icons who
weren't actually straight right here